let's bring you some breaking news I was
telling you a few minutes ago we had to
heard from the chancellor quasi quateng
well this is what he's had to say on a
visit this afternoon to businesses in
Darlington all following the turmoil
caused by the mini budget last week
very much because we have people here
Treasury Office very much interested in
investment zones our growth plan really
getting Britain moving and that's why
I'm here it's a great company Cummings
great history and engineering and I'm
very very focused on driving investment
and driving growth now in the last few
days we've seen the pound fall we've
seen the cost of government borrowing
Rockets has your mini budget been a
major economic disaster
what we're focusing on is delivering the
growth plan and making sure with things
like our energy intervention that people
right across this country are protected
and without growth you're not going to
get the Public Services we're not going
to generate the income and the tax
revenue to pay for the public services
that we want to see and that's why the
mini budget was absolutely essential in
resetting the debate around growth and
focusing us on delivering much better
growth outcomes for our people one
people one group of people who are
seeing growth at the moment are people
with mortgages what do you say to people
whose mortgage interest rates are rising
as a result of your Economic Policy so
we're absolutely protecting people right
across the country if you look at our
energy intervention people with
potentially facing bills of six thousand
five hundred pounds next year and
because of the intervention we've
limited the average uh Bill the average
household Bill to 2 500 pounds that's a
huge saving that everyone
people normal incomes are benefiting
from they're being wiped out though
aren't they by the increasing cost of
mortgage
I uh think that if you look at the
government's plan we've got the growth
plan we've got the energy intervention
that's saving thousands of pounds a year
we're putting more people's uh income
into their own Pockets through tax cuts
and we're very very focused on making
sure that the cost of living pressures
uh can be uh can be withstood by
Ordinary People right up and down this
country are you going to keep the
previous government's promise to put
benefits up in April by this month's
rate of inflation that's 10 so we're
talking about uh how big people in the
round it's premature for me to come to a
decision on that but that we are
absolutely focused on making sure that
the most vulnerable in our society are
protected through what could be a
challenge with that and and the same for
pensions the triple lock is that
guaranteed to go up at this month's
inflation rate 10 percent the Prime
Minister has uh been absolutely
committed to the triple lock and we're
absolutely committed to maintaining it